well Thank You Leslie and and thank you
for all your great questions today it
was a real pleasure
to have such a degree of engagement in
terms of asking questions about what
works and what doesn't and also trying
to understand how we can go forward
sustainably with approaches that can
actually work so I would encourage us to
participate in interactively I'm a firm
believer in the inverted classroom and
by that we've seen a couple of smart
small lectures in the form of videos so
far but now we have an opportunity to
interact with this material and so I
would encourage you to ask your
questions as we go along because I think
that can facilitate the discussion
really effectively so thank you for
joining us today
recently I did a session for a group
called Rex and it stands for a
relationship our carbon footprints are
normally a depressing story about how
many gigatonnes of carbon we've emitted
over the past 200 years and it can be
very daunting it can be very depressing
it can be very demotivating and I've
seen the story time and time again and
recently what we've come up with and
what I've learned about our not only
talking about our carbon footprints the
10 countries that have emitted the most
carbon historically in the world are
mainly Western countries of those 10
countries only 2 countries have not put
a price on carbon and they are Russia
and the United States so we're in a tie
for dead last but we have an opportunity
to change that and I'll talk with you a
little bit about how that can enter in
today but carbon hand prints are much
more positive and the way I think about
carbon hand prints is how can we take
positive action and guide by example to
actually make a difference in our lives
at the Gigaton scale and that's those
are the kinds of projects I'll talk with
you about today and that is what can we
do that's effective entrepreneurial and
can make a significant dent in restoring
carbon balance so that's what I mean by
carbon hand prints I recently ran across
this amusing photo of what I imagined to
be the New York subways after
which hurricane was it sandy and my good
friend John Englander was for a couple
years corresponding me with me about his
book that called high tide on Main
Street which came out six weeks before
sandy you couldn't ask for a better
advertisement and what I find time and
again is that when you're on the right
track
things like this happen in other words
his book came out six weeks later the
New York City Subway became a scuba
diving event our situation and and and
you know for better or worse
John Englander was was then doing the
book tour circuit because it was so
popular to try to understand how these
issues are hitting home the point is
really to be understanding what are the
what are the issues I saw a slide in the
last couple weeks that said with
expected sea level rise over the coming
century we're looking at annual costs in
New York City that exceed about three
billion dollars a year in terms of
infrastructure and in other cities like
Mumbai Bangladesh China six to twelve
billion dollars per year in terms of the
cost of increasing sea level so these
are our issues that are measured in
billions and trillions of dollars and
their key question is how can we
monetize these opportunities partly
because that's the way our
entrepreneurial system works but part of
it is how do we connect from the
billions of dollars a year that
reinsurance companies insure to
something that we can actually do to
restore climate change so one of the
things I'll mention briefly today is
reinsuring the reinsurance companies
because that's something we can do with
some of the technologies we're talking
about and it's these kind of couplings
to our capital system that really make a
difference one of my advisors at Cal
Tech Carver Mead said that companies are
the engines of creation they are the
vehicles by which we scale and it's that
intersection of engineering
entrepreneurship and climate change that
give us the tools
to actually make a difference in this
world so that's the theme behind what
we're doing did you have a question yes
no okay
so we started nearly ten years ago and
ten years ago we went to the
International coral reef symposium where
there were a thousand coral reef
biologists lamenting the demise of their
coral reef ecosystem it's estimated at
the Australian Institute of Marine
Science that this century the Great
Barrier Reef will become a geologic
relic already we've seen calcium
accumulation rates drop thirteen percent
since 1990 and the coral reefs and this
year and last year we've seen 50 to 90
percent coral bleaching in the reefs off
Hawaii and these reef South American
Samoa
I never thought I would see Hawaiian
coral reefs bleach in my lifetime
because it's cooler water it's a lot
cooler than American Samoa but we did it
it happened last October 50% coral
bleaching so a very serious situation
this year's El Nino is expected to
produce similar coral bleaching levels
and this is very serious you know corals
live within five degrees of mortality
their entire lives and so they are the
Canaries in the coal mine they are the
ecosystem that's living on the edge and
are the first to go during major
extinctions now there have been five
extinctions on earth mass extinctions in
the history of the earth and they each
and every time we're preceded by the
demise of the coral reefs the sixth one
they're calling the Anthropocene which
is the notion of imperiling half the
species on earth this time at the hand
of man due to catastrophic climate
disruption and it's a real challenge the
front line here are these coral reefs
and so one thing we did back in 2008 was
to embark on an effort to see if we
could reverse coral bleaching on the
coral reefs and what we did with a
limited amount of support by private
foundation
was that we organized a system we flew
down to American Samoa and we managed to
experimentally cool off a small region
of coral reef by one degree Celsius and
we expected and then we sucked and
waited expecting it for maybe take a
month for some of these corals to come
back to color well in less than 24 hours
these corals returned to color and very
intensely and it was an amazing result
now how what is the scaled version of
this we've been working for the past
five years with the Honolulu seawater
air-conditioning company which next year
will be commissioning a hundred megawatt
deep seawater air-conditioning system
for half of downtown Honolulu what it's
going to do is run chilled water through
the streets of downtown Honolulu to all
of the high-rises and those high-rises
will get their cooling water not from
shipping fossil fuel 10,000 kilometers
burning it so you can produce
electricity so you can run your air
conditioner you can imagine how many
efficiencies there are in there but
instead pumping deep water up from 500
meters down at a temperature of 44
degrees running it through a titanium
heat exchanger exchanging 100 megawatts
of heat and then out following at 56
Fahrenheit now what's fascinating to me
is after all that process is done they
have a hundred and fifty megawatts
thermal left over going back to the sea
and the plan that we have is to actually
seasonally utilize that hundred and
fifty megawatts thermal to seasonally
cool kilometres of coral reef and
reverse bleaching or prevent that
bleaching from occurring Wesley
temperature it's also ocean
acidification
but you're saying bringing temperatures
it has an enormous effect there's been a
lot of press on ocean acidification and
it's an important effect and it's real
but when we're looking let's say triage
on the operating table and we're looking
at corals the reason they're bleaching
today is thermally induced photo
bleaching the high temperatures make the
coral polyps and the zooxanthellae
inside of them
sensitive to light and so that multiple
that that multiplicative combination of
high temperature and light causes the
bleaching to occur the bleaching means
they're on life support
they've lost ninety eighty ninety
percent of their food source namely the
zooxanthellae and they're living on life
support
they have little tentacles like
barnacles do and they can try to eke out
a living on clear coral water which
doesn't have much plankton to try to
scrape out a living and survive but
they've stopped producing calcium
they've stopped
laying down additional corals they are
they have a compromised immune system
half the time they set they die from
disease other times they can be taken
over by macro algae and sometimes they
can come back but what's typically
happened is we've seen a binary
decimation of the coral cover each time
you get a major bleaching event and they
will go along at the lower level for a
few years till the next hurricane comes
or the next bleaching event happens and
so you're losing by binary factors of
two each time and you look at the
Caribbean you've gone from the 1970s
where I went
fortunate enough to go diving then in
seeing coral cover in the 30 40 percent
range down to today where you see coral
cover in the five percent range the US
Virgin Islands are another example of
this Jamaica again also where it's been
taken over by macro algae and we've lost
a lot of the corals so it's a really
critical issue partly because a quarter
of all marine species spend some time of
their lifecycle on the coral reefs these
are the nurseries of the oceans and what
we found time and again is when you
collapse one ecosystem it cascades on to
the next ecosystem the pelagic fish the
shorebirds the marine birds there's a
collapse of ecosystems so our system to
cool coral reefs is a band-aid it's an
attempt to keep a slice of this marine
ecosystem alive at a time when we're
losing thousands of square kilometers
and that's very depressing and but the
thing to keep that gives me hope is that
coral reefs can come back and if we can
use the band-aid during the difficult
decades to come we can rebalance our
carbon budget and we can actually get
these coral reefs back to productivity
the key is to have a big enough section
of coral reef a big enough high-value
reef that they can continue reproducing
within that zone and that's the vision
behind the coral reef cooling this is
big enough to do things on a kilometer
scale and what we prove here we can take
to Guam and the US Navy I'm happy to say
has adopted our suggestion to utilize
deep sea water air conditioning for
their marine bases their air force bases
in their Navy bases 40 megawatts of
cooling in Guam next to really high
value reefs so we're looking at being
able to build in the infrastructure now
that actually can actually make a
difference and preserve high-value reefs
in the Coral Triangle so that's part of
the philosophy behind where we're going
with this there's another event that I
have to share with you because it blows
me away and it's very very poorly
understood what if I told you that there
was a single plant in the history of the
earth that historically and
single-handedly pulled three thousand
parts per million co2 out of the
atmosphere in less than a million years
how many people have heard of Azolla
show hence one or two there was this
event and it's on Wikipedia look it up
the Azolla event 50 million years ago
where one plant all by itself in the
Arctic Ocean right near the North Pole
pulled three thousand parts per million
co2 out of the atmosphere
single-handedly in 800,000 years to me
this is a positive outlier this is what
I look for in nature when nature does
something without our interference at
all that solves our problem this is what
we have to listen to Azula is an amazing
plant if this tiny little plant like
this and what makes it so effective is
that it's a symbiosis between the plant
itself and a cyanobacterium that lives
in the plant produces omega-3s fixes
nitrogen does all sorts of wonderful
things this plant is an aquatic fern it
grows 10 seminary's thick on the top of
fresh water how did it survive in the
Arctic Ocean two reasons one the Arctic
Ocean was
not open very limited circulation
secondly ambient temperatures were 20 to
30 degrees Celsius and thirdly you had
phosphate pouring out of the rivers into
the Arctic Ocean so what happened near
the river mouths you had a zola growing
taking all a phosphate it could and
growing and guess what the doubling time
of azolla is two days can anyone say
lilypad problem or lilypad solution this
is incredible so the idea of Missoula
blows me away every summer Zola would
cover the Arctic Ocean how the Arctic
Ocean salty but what happens is the Zola
grows out over the Arctic Ocean and as
it does so it creates its keeps the
waves down and keeps mixing down and the
fresh water creates a lens on the
surface propagates through the Azolla
and creates more fresh water on the
surface so it keeps growing and growing
with a doubling time of two days this is
why we have to harness biology to solve
the climate problem biology has been
fixing carbon for three billion years we
have to learn from the past and learn
from nature to understand what natural
systems we can leverage to sustainably
sequester gigatonnes of carbon it's my
ambition my personal ambition to
sequester a Giga ton of carbon in my
lifetime or at least a Giga ton of
carbon dioxide or cause it to be
sequestered and all of us I believe
should have this ambition it is doable
it is doable to create businesses
successful sustainable businesses that
can actually do this and it's the key to
sustaining the planet that we live on
so can we mimic Gazzola can we find an
opportunity to do this what happened
with the Izola every summer an arctic
ocean a million square kilometers of
azolla would grow and every fall and
winter a million square kilometers of
azolla would die and sink to the bottom
and what's fascinating about this is
that the Arctic Ocean we know was anoxic
in the middle and deep and so that
azolla
would sink and go into the anoxic deaths
with no oxygen where it would be turned
into the Alaska oil that we find today
and that was that was 50 million years
ago now that simple system in
than 800,000 years pulled down 3,000
parts per million of carbon dioxide we
would be happy to do one thirtieth of
that that would take us back to 350 so
it's an incredible opportunity and I
look at places like the Santa Barbara
Channel the Black Sea in other places
that are already anoxic at the bottom in
the middle and I think how can we
harness something like azolla
to ensure food security avert food riots
and water wars and yet at the same time
sequester this scale of carbon these are
the kind of natural positive outliers
that I look to to actually do this and
my engineering work there's this notion
of a positive outlier that I think we
all need to understand and learn I
learned about it because I heard about a
doctor that went to Vietnam after the
Vietnam War and people were starving the
children were starving
everyone was starving and dying there
wasn't enough food and the doctor went
down there and it was just disaster
story after disaster story in all these
places but there were a few confusing
positive outliers there were a few
children that weren't dying there are a
few children that were actually doing
better and he went and studied what
these positive outliers were and what he
found was this the kids that were
surviving were getting four half cups of
rice per day instead of two cups of rice
per day and they were getting little
bits of crab shell and primp shell that
were normally reserved for the adults
and these two tiny practices were enough
for them to accumulate protein and body
mass rather than losing it and dying and
so that ended up transforming the
operations and recovery efforts in
Vietnam and the net result was that
millions of children survived rather
than dying these positive outliers is
what we as engineers need to seek in our
basic science in our engineering in our
research to find sustainable ways to
actually save the planet and I think as
Ola is one of those examples and I would
love to work with all of you to figure
out how do we harness technologies and
plants and organisms like Azula to
restore food security restore carbon
on land and get the carbon back where it
came from and that is in the soils and
the seas question do I believe you spoke
about this in the link that you sent us
with questions and answers as well so if
anybody doesn't check that up there are
so much valuable information in there
and your time and cyanobacteria takes us
back a couple lectures too so this is
this is profound yep definitely check
out the link and you're willing to
course what a further of the length I
think certainly - I would encourage
people to add comments to the Google
document that we're accumulating with
questions and answers and I think that's
a great way to continue the dialog
online as well as offline and so I think
that would be great would encourage that
very much and that's not the last we'll
hear about sign of bacteria because
they'll enter into the marine
permaculture concept as well later in
the session so I look forward to doing
that so just in the last two weeks I
managed to read Tim Flannery's
atmosphere of hope and I'm fortunate
enough to be able to see him tonight in
San Francisco so if any of you have
questions for him I will be happy to
relay those what impresses me so much
about Tim is that he has collected the
world's knowledge about what we can do
sustainably and has organized it into
this book and is actively working on
solutions that are practical that work
and are sustainable and he's classified
all the things we can do into three
categories the zero a thing in my mind
is reduce carbon intensity I mean number
one it's number zero is to actually take
public transportation reduce the
intensity of our transportation move our
electricity infrastructure into into low
carbon intensity approaches as well and
I will cite to my good friend Amory
Lovins
who has written reinventing fire and
that book is a prescription for carbon
reducing and it's talking about the four
ways the four major areas where we can
actually reduce carbon intensity and go
to well he likes to say a five point
five trillion dollar net present value
to being green which fundamentally is
about
moving quickly toward and accelerating
our progress towards fully sustainable
practices so we can reduce the carbon
intensity of our civilization now that
can take care of 80% of it and the
question is how do we actually go carbon
negative or I like to say climate
positive how do we go climate positive
these are the approaches that can
actually pull carbon out of the
atmosphere because even if we stop today
as you know we're at an effective
greenhouse gas level of four hundred and
thirty parts per million today and it's
increasing and the challenge is can we
keep below two degrees Celsius warming
can we do all these things
so Tim talks about three ways the first
is adaptation and that is get used to it
although I'm not sure that wearing a
scuba tank in a New York subway is the
right way to attempt but adaptation is
one approach it's a problem for cities
like the town of Kivalina that were
mentioned in this arctic area and that's
one of the cities that we're actually
working in it's a problem in many of
those areas and how do we say adaptation
to a hundred million climate refugees in
Bangladesh and China
not to mention India and how about the
eleven trillion dollars in real estate
in the Gulf Coast and the east coast of
the United States that's at risk from
sea level rise
so adaptation has a very high price tag
the second is geoengineering and you've
heard some areas of geoengineering as I
wrote in our question-answer session I
view driving our SUVs around and taking
high-intensity carbon flights as acts of
geoengineering why because we know the
outcome of business as usual we know
what's going to happen with the coral
reefs we know we're going to collapse
these ecosystems
we're know we know that we're at the
cusp of the Anthropocene which is that
we're actually wiping out species faster
than we ever have before
and that's the kind of legacy I would
hope that we could leave to our children
the legacy of have leaving the planet
with as many species as we arrived
because that's irreversible and this
notion of the Anthropocene you know
there's seven million species on this
planet that
though and it's up to us to protect
those species and protect that diversity
and partly because half the medicines we
get are coming off the coral reef are
they coming from biological metaphors
and we're just reaching the quantified
century of biology this century so to
lose so many species right at the cusps
pun of understanding them to me is a
real tragedy and so that's a challenge
an opportunity I like to think of some
of the techniques that have been talked
about in this course as reverse
geoengineering because we're trying to
undo some of the damage that's been done
over the last 200 years and especially
especially when we talk about the Third
Way I mean there are the techniques of
using sulfate aerosols there are the
techniques of trying to it's almost like
window dressing right because you can
you can cool off the earth but you can't
reduce the ocean acidification now in
this decade and next decade it's
temperature that's really critical in
killing the coral reefs but a shot ocean
acidification is affecting diatomaceous
plankton and it's affecting plankton
that required calcium for for their and
silica for their operation and it's
going to be a much bigger problem in the
years ahead
so the third way is what Tim
characterizes as pulling oxygen out of
the atmosphere and I will say that can
be done biologically chemically and
physically and finding effective
approaches that can sustainably pull the
carbon out of the atmosphere and and
leave it out of the atmosphere and put
it into seas and soils where they are
stable for hundreds to thousands of
years and the United Nations has in
their program if you can keep the carbon
out of the atmosphere for a hundred
years you get a carbon credit that's
under the Kyoto Protocol's so with that
in mind that's a long enough time scale
where the United Nations is actually
endorsed this approach and so we have to
look at how we can do this sustainably
and profitably particularly in a time
where we don't have a price on carbon
and we have relatively inexpensive
fossil fuels so it's a difficult
challenge to understand how can we
address this but I'll talk about several
approach
tim discusses two of these in his book
and one of them are actually storing
carbon dioxide and marine sediments now
I thought this would be almost
impossible but Tim in his book discusses
something that is in fact sustainable
did you know that carbon dioxide is
compressible in fact it's far more
compressible than seawater so much so
that if you take liquid carbon dioxide
which is normally a bit less dense than
sea water perhaps and you get it down
three kilometers it becomes denser than
sea water and wants to keep sinking now
normally there'd be concerned if you
made a pool of carbon dioxide lake at
the bottom of the sea it would
eventually dissolve and mix in with the
ocean and it would eventually come back
up but researchers that Tim describes in
his book have actually analyzed and
determined that by storing the co2 in
holes in the marine sediment the co2 is
denser than the sea so it stays in the
in the holes it infiltrates into the
sediments and then it forms hydrates and
the hydrates are solid so these solid
hydrates can stay in the sediment for
millennia and it's estimated that within
the economic zone of the United States
alone we can store thousands of years of
co2 which is really surprising
Leslee usually happens when temperatures
continue to rise in temperatures
continue to rise so his sudden release
it's a stable enough when it's this
virgin year there there is a concern
with that and it's a major concern for
methane clathrates
co2 clathrates have a melting
temperature of two degrees Celsius or
colder methane clathrates have a melting
temperature of seven degrees celsius or
colder but there's far more of them if
you thought we had a lot of coal on the
earth it turns out we have perhaps more
carbon locked up in methane clathrates
on the sea floor than all of the coal in
carbon all the carbon and coal it is
amazing and what's even more daunting is
that the USGS has determined that there
are 73 trillion cubic feet of tech
the recoverable reserves of methane
clathrates on the North Slope of Alaska
alone and those are shallow shallow
methane sediments so if you think about
the Arctic Ocean warming and you think
about the warming shallow seas people
are already observing methane bubbling
up offshore in the permafrost this is a
ticking time bomb this is something we
need to do about it's a runaway feedback
loop I can't think of anything positive
about it they call the positive feedback
loops
these are runaway feedback loops and we
need to address them early with
techniques like Leslie's developing the
silica spheres that can keep it white
and keep it frozen longer we have to
keep those temperatures down to keep
those methane clathrates from going now
in the deep sea at 3 kilometers or
deeper you have an enormous reservoir of
cold water and it is renewed each winter
so it's a very renewable source resource
one of my advisors at Caltech Richard
Fineman loved to say there's plenty of
room at the bottom and he was talking
about scaling technology down in the
nanoscale I like to use it for the ocean
there is plenty of room at the bottom
that bodes well for deep sea water air
conditioning it bodes well for ocean
thermal energy conversion and it bodes
well for utilizing all of the sea the
middle and deep ocean to actually
balance our carbon sustain our seas and
ensure food productivity for decades to
come
the second technique that Tim talks
about in his book is another amazing
technique and this is a positive outlier
barred from Mars do you know that the
polar caps of Mars are not only water
ice they're also carbon dioxide ice
they're also dry ice and they're
seasonal well it so happens that on the
high plateau of Alaska of Antarctica in
the wintertime you're within 30 degrees
Celsius of the temperature at which
carbon dioxide snows out of the air and
onto the ground and with a small
addition of wind turbines down there
there's been a calculation done where
you could actually build an air
conditioner that
cool the air by 30 Celsius and they
could get up over a foot of carbon
dioxide snow each night each day I
should say night because it's each
24-hour period during the Antarctic
winter accumulating feet upon feet upon
feet of carbon dioxide directly on the
cap cover it with ice keep it cold let
it run all summer I mean I'm the summer
is just being reflected by the water ice
above it but you could accumulate
massive amounts of carbon dioxide ice
right there on the polar cap and perhaps
do it sustainably and potentially or the
winds are enormous there you could
potentially do it all with wind energy
so there's another fascinating area that
is potentially Giga tons of carbon in
this case physical the physical
sequestration of carbon there have also
been chemical approaches professors like
David Keith at Harvard have looked at
extraction of co2 directly from the air
and then there are biological techniques
which I've been specializing in at the
climate foundation we've been working on
biochar technologies and associated
Terra Preta on on soils and then the C's
marine permaculture with an eye towards
food security one of the questions today
was how do we afford all this if you're
just gonna pile it up in marine
sediments and there's no price on carbon
what can we do well there are two
approaches to that and what I've learned
as an engineer technologist is that
usually the technology is 15 or 20
percent of the problem and for better or
worse more than half the problem is
actually political or building the
political will to actually make a
difference that said there are some very
good groups that are working in this
area and just two over the last two
years at Climate Foundation we've been
strongly supporting the citizens climate
Lobby why because they believe in
laser-focus to develop a bipartisan
solution called the carbon dividend that
carbon dividend puts a predictable and
rising price on carbon it's focused on a
revenue neutral approach that's modeled
after the Alaska oil dividend which has
been a very successful and popular
program
over the past thirty years in a
Republican state so here you have a
Republican state that's got this
incredible carbon dividend makes a huge
difference to the people and the way it
works is there's a levy charged on
carbon at its source and it's
distributed on an annual basis to every
adult resident of the state why not have
a national carbon dividend that's the
question we're asking it's our position
that if the Republicans are really
serious about electing a Republican
president they need to adopt and
initiate a carbon dividend in order to
take leadership on carbon balance it's
that important and we think it's
politically important as well the social
cost of carbon is measured 30 to 80
dollars depending on your estimates per
per ton of co2 these are the social cost
we're dealing with the cost of real
estate of disruptions of climate
refugees these are serious issues and we
feel that putting a price on carbon and
doing it sooner rather than later can
make an enormous difference in our lives
to that end the proposal by the citizens
climate Lobby starts at $15 per ton and
fossil co2 emitted there was a study
done by a very conservative think tank
called Remy in Washington and this study
analyzed the economic outcomes of the
carbon dividend and the result was they
there was no economic argument against
adding a carbon dividend it was revenue
neutral it created jobs it was good for
the economy it was good for the
environment and these are the kinds of
tools that we need in order to actually
make a change
did everyone hear about the Keystone XL
cancellation wasn't that an incredible
result I mean there's a positive outlier
I worked for years with Bill McKibben
against what seemed insurmountable odds
and yet to achieve this miracle and
overnight success five years in the
making
gives us inspiration that principles
like the carbon dividend can work and so
I would encourage all of you to get
active with this I'm actually a part of
the citizens climate Lobby Mountainview
chapter which meets a few short miles
away from here they welcome student and
other participation and it's about
getting involved and
active and so I would encourage all of
you to check out citizens climate Lobby
because they are super focused on this
one issue that is a tie it's a rising
tide that lifts all boats people can
choose to they get a dividend check in
the mail they can choose to pay at the
pump for higher priced gasoline or pay
for renewable energy but the non carbon
alternatives end up being far less
expensive over time using this kind of
approach so this is something that we
think makes a huge difference there is
something called border externalities
and that is countries that don't have
carbon dividends you have to reconcile
that that's already within the
International Trade Organization
regulations the WTO so it fits within
that framework and it honors those
guidelines
in addition technologies like biochar is
a border opportunity in this case it's
the border between the air and the
rhizosphere between the atmosphere and
the rhizosphere and that border
externality is substantial in other
words the third way represents ways that
we pull carbon actively out of the
atmosphere and we put it into soils and
seas and if we can certify it by
independent third parties let's say this
carbon is pulling out coming out of the
atmosphere and staying out that's like a
credit that is a credit just as if we
were here in the United States with a
carbon dividend producing low carbon
products and shipping them overseas to
countries that didn't have a carbon
dividend so the same border
externalities are something that we can
accommodate in the engineering sense
into biochar technologies marine
permaculture x' and other technologies
that we've mentioned that pull carbon
out of the atmosphere and into the soils
and seas so I see this as a key
opportunity right at the intersection of
politics and engineering half the
problem is political will the other half
is system engineering so this course is
an engineering course I'm going to spend
more time on the engineering side but
it's important for us all to be
multidisciplinary in the sense of
understanding everything that needs to
be done and that sometimes means working
on the political side as well as on the
engineer
to actually get the problem solved so
we're faced with a collapsed price on
carbon today we're faced with cheap gas
and we have to consider food security
for our own species and other species on
this planet how do we try to solve these
problems in a scalable way in a way that
lets us build industries and scale to
the Gigaton level and how do we can do
it sustainably well we have in this case
solution one solution - I have first to
talk with you about our efforts on food
security on land we've been developing
biochar reactors and Terra Preta for
since 2009 at this it's been six years
and we've gotten substantial support
from the Gates Foundation and have
developed a set of biochar reactors that
can solve santé sanitation problems and
developing nations and also in the
United States and can also begin to
address restoring depleted lands for six
thousand years man has done a great job
of turning forests into deserts but it's
really hard to turn it around to
actually take those deserts and bring
them back to productivity this February
I was fortunate enough to participate in
the urban soil conference in Los Angeles
and there at USC or nearby we I had the
great fortune not only to speak about
biochar but to meet some of the top soil
scientist in the world Allan savory
works in Africa and has studied
restoration of soils we had incredibly
knowledgeable people about living soils
and it was fascinating to me to realize
there is a critical mass coming together
and we actually have the understanding
that we need to turn deserts back to
productivity why is this important
because there is a huge effect on the
depleted lands in the United States this
is a picture of the biochar reactor
containerized system that can actually
provide sanitation for thousands of
people per day while at the same time
generating sanitary biochar that can
actually be part of the solution to
restoring depleted lands I keep talking
about
pleated lands wise is so important I ran
across a figure and I have to
double-check the calculations but Easter
Island went from a population of
approaching a hundred thousand people
before Western man ever met them and
when Western man arrived there were
about 300 people left what happened they
chopped down all of their rainforests
they made these they were making these
giant canoes that they used for hunting
tuna fish so they would make a giant
dugout canoe they'd go out get the fish
and come back but somebody chopped down
the last tree I don't know what was
going on in their mind when they were
doing it the last tree was chopped down
it became you know grassland at best but
desert at worst and they had to resort
to cannibalism food riots you name it
and by the time Western man arrived
there were a few hundred people left on
the island the world will reach the
population density of Easter Island in
the 2020s what does that mean for our
entire planetary island what does it
mean how do we actually avert the
catastrophe that befell Easter Island
these are the key questions in my mind
and that's why we try to propel and
motivate carbon balance in the context
of food security why because we have
billions of people to feed we have close
to 10 billion people on this earth
already there's an attempt to do what we
call the soft landing and that is to
find a way to voluntarily manage our
global population to the point where we
can live more sustainably and reduce our
numbers because quite frankly we've had
such a pressure on the other 7 million
species that how many more doublings can
humans endure before we've wiped out
most of the species on earth so these
are the key questions we need to try to
address this map shows depleted lands
across the world in red you have the
most degraded soils in yellow degraded
soils and you look at countries
including the United States where we
have degraded soils I'm working in India
with with the Gates Foundation most of
India
has very degraded soil and the question
is how do we return it to productivity
there's been thousands of years of
farming there and and yet the problem is
how do we return it to productivity well
from this conference from this urban
spell conference I've learned that there
is a positive outlier and that positive
outlier is in the form of biochar which
acts like a sponge and retains water and
nutrients creates drought resistance
biochar added to the base of compost is
really fascinating because it improves
the aeration of compost the compost
inoculates the char with effective
microorganisms including my horizon
symbiosis fungus and that create
dendritic path nutrient pathways between
the char that has buffered nature macro
nutrients and the roots of plants and
the roots of the plants then return
sugars that are fixed in the fungus and
actually increased the carbon so that
Terra Preta in Brazil is a growing
living carbon soil that 1,500 years
later you can pick up a piece of
charcoal and look at the grains of wood
on that piece of charcoal from 1500
years ago
that's how permanent it is not only is
it succeeding in being the richest soil
in all of South America accidental by
the way it wasn't out in the fields it
was behind the kitchen window where they
threw the charcoal the fish bones all
kinds of waste and a hundred years later
maybe they noticed oh the weeds are
growing better behind the kitchen window
than they are out in the fields so how
do we recreate this positive outlier see
once again it's a matter of wandering
around and noticing the positive
outliers that can save the world these
are the accidental discoveries this is
the way the ways that major
transformations occur day in and day out
most of the time is by accident and so
keep alert for those little accidents of
nature and man those little those little
positive outliers so that this is
biochar as part of it the third part is
that those effective microorganisms
end up adding to the soils and so
literally it's possible to combine these
effective amendments these soil
amendments to restore depleted soils
back to productivity and do what we call
extensive agriculture and by extensive
agriculture sometimes when you try to
push on a rope you know you just don't
get a lot of results and that is when as
you try to drive intensive agriculture
to higher and higher yields and higher
higher productivity you run into limits
now there are several definitions for
extensive agriculture but for me it's
about taking land that was used in the
past and is no longer arable and
restoring it to productivity this is an
opportunity for us to really make a
difference in agriculture and food
security on earth and at the same time
all that biochar that we're putting into
the soil is staying for centuries my
good friend and partner johannes layman
professor at Cornell talks about biochar
in the soil as soil capital soil capital
because when you put carbon back in the
soil you're increasing the productivity
of that soil for decades to come
so it's as if you're depositing
something in a bank account and you're
getting the interest coming off of that
in terms of higher food productivity so
carbon levels are a great way a proxy
for thinking about soil carbon an
example are the Iowa corn lands they
started out before man's intervention at
6% carbon
why because you had prairie fires and
other things that inefficiently
accumulated carbon over millennia after
a hundred years of corn farming we're
down to three percent carbon in the soil
so it's still going but it's not going
so well and guess what in California
with three to four crops a year and all
these rotations we never let the soil
rest we're down below 1% carbon so
there's a huge challenge and a huge
opportunity right here in our backyard
and that is how do we get carbon back
into the soil how do we restore depleted
lands and how do we do it very
efficiently water wise and that's the
recipe that we have for restoring food
security and food productivity
one gallon of gas is 19 pounds of carbon
the forest can certainly capture carbon
we've already altered most of this for
us and so the question is can we and
true food security at the same time
we're ensuring carbon balance we think
the answer is yes and the way we address
that is that half of the carbon may come
off this the land as food but half of it
remains as corn stover as crops double
as agricultural residues many of those
agricultural residues can be utilized
and if they're utilized an effective way
with a mobile transportable array of
pyrolyze errs that convert to biochar we
can get carbon back into the soil and do
it efficiently enough we're also using
green waste we're using mean--if
municipal solid waste we're able to
produce chars from urban waste products
that are sustainable have low enough and
have low metals levels and also are
eliminating eliminating pathogens and so
that opportunity need to go full circle
is a big deal
and char enters in two macro nutrient
cycling we were experiencing peak
phosphate in our farming right now we
have a broken phosphate kappa a broken
phosphate cycle in the united states the
phosphates is mined in Florida it gets
hauled to the Midwest where it grows
corn the corn gets hauled to let's say
states like North Carolina where it goes
and feeds pigs the pigs poop the poop
goes into the Chesapeake Bay and we kill
the softshell brat a crab and we over
utri Phi the waters in the Chesapeake
Bay this is not a cycle it's a broken
sea biochar can come in at the pig level
even at the corn level and we can take
that phosphate recycle it get it back on
the farm it's about recycling phosphate
it's about recycling nitrate nitrates a
real problem because nitrate is soluble
when you put nitrate fertilizer on the
ground and it rains guess where it goes
goes right into the groundwater and in
my own my home state of Massachusetts my
hometown of Woods Hole and and Cape Cod
they're talking about spending 3 billion
dollars to wire up 100,000 homes with a
traditional 1800 sewer system what a
crazy idea that ends up being twenty to
fifty thousand dollars per household to
run an antiquated sewer system and guess
what you're not
the phosphate you're not cycling the
nitrate this is all because those septic
tanks that they told us were so great
they may take care of the pathogens they
don't address the nitrate the nitrate
goes right into the ground and goes
right into the waterways and right into
the estuaries so our challenge and our
opportunity is to have that nutrient
cycling what is biochar do biochar has a
very high cation exchange capacity yet
adds Sorbs the phosphate directly onto
the surface of the char that attracts
the my erisa it attracts the fungus it
attracts organisms that harvest and
what's more important is those organisms
that take up residence on the char they
grab onto the nitrate anytime it's it's
available and they put it in their cells
and they actually effectively make the
nitrate biologically insoluble so when
it rains you don't lose the nitrate the
nitrate stays near the roots of the
plants where it can go again so now it's
all about fertilizer efficiency it's
about reducing our carbon intensity you
know more than 1% of the electricity in
the world goes to produce nitrate
fertilizers so if we can actually focus
on how do we use our fertilizer more
efficiency how do we ensure food
security using these sustainable
practices we can go from a petro
chemical fertilizer world which is all
about get addicted to fertilizers like
you get addicted to sugar
you always need more and more and more
carbohydrates if you're on a insulin
cycle it's like you're getting ready to
hibernate or something the same
challenge and opportunity occurs with
these soils that if you have a dead soil
that requires it requires more and more
and more petrol chemical fertilizer each
year it's a vicious cycle there's an
alternative the alternative is living
soil that combines biochar compost and
effective microorganisms and it holds on
to macronutrients near the roots of the
plant where it's useful and by the way
that compost and that char holds on to
the water during droughts that's been
demonstrated that plants with biochar do
many times better than plants without
during droughts which is becoming an
increasing problem in California and
other drought stricken regions around
the world so this is about all about
that cycle here's an example of that
cycle every year on lane
and a hundred Giga tons of carbon is
fixed by our land plants and every year
honor Giga tons rots what if we could
take just a few percent of that carbon
and we could in fact offset it to char
put it back in the soils increase our
soil capital in the in the soils and do
that year after year after year we'd be
building up quite a bank account
wouldn't we so that's a real opportunity
is to take part of this natural cycle
and with a permaculture in this case a
soil permaculture be able to do this now
half of those half of that hundred Giga
tons is in trees and for us half of it
let's say is in man's agriculture but
that still may be about sixty gigatonnes
of carbon fixation in man's agriculture
of which 30 Giga tons may be crop
residues of which half of that's carbon
so that's a that could be about 15 Giga
tons and even if we are only 20%
efficient at harnessing that crop
residue that's still 3 Giga tons of
carbon per year if applied at low
efficiency on a global scale and that's
what we mean by gigatonnes of carbon
balance in in soils is the potential is
enormous if we find an inexpensive way
to apply this on a global scale and this
is what we see is one of the major
opportunities going forward so biochar
is is graphene-based disordered sheets
of graphene that are very
recalcitrant they high temperature they
can be used as a fuel but they're better
used as money in the bank in the soil
itself and it's I've mentioned briefly
you can hold the carbon for a hundred to
thousand years we built a first stage
reactor in 2012 we demonstrated that at
the u.s. biochar initiative Sonoma
Conference with our team here and then
we went on to build a larger system and
this larger system is deployed in
eastern United States and also one of
these is deployed with concurrent
engineering in Bangalore India and I'll
be flying there next week to work with
our engineers on the ground in Bangalore
India and then to attend the Terra Preta
sanitation conference Terra Preta means
ARC soil dark earth in portuguese and it
was these portuguese soils that
originally started the process it
appears to be effective in sanitation
it's also very effective in restoring
food security and restoring soil
productivity and so that'll be the focus
of that work and it's really going from
our urban waste environment to
sustainable soils that what this program
is all about
we demonstrated in 2014 a system in
Delhi the system works by conserving
energy very carefully recapturing heat
and enabling the entire system to
operate sustainably using the exo
thermal characteristics of the biochar
production process itself and using the
the gas that comes off as a vehicle to
actually do partial oxidation we
developed a set of specifications for
the system I'd be happy to go over those
in more detail with you later and we see
a number of potential revenue streams
for the transportable omniprocessor or
t.o.p as we call it and they include
Sanitation tipping fees biochar itself
producing energy water and agricultural
services and products so in summary
these are some pictures of the of the
fair preparation and we applied this
technology not only in India but also
here in the United States so we were
funded through two rounds of funding
with a NAFTA Commission for
environmental cooperation this
organization is focused on what can we
do across our borders in Mexico United
States and Canada to actually make
things sustainable and it turned out
that village that Arctic village that
leslie mentioned earlier this morning
Kivalina is a system that is a village
that has no sustainable water system and
no sustainable sanitation system either
and so we're hoping to address those
issues President Obama last month flew
Air Force One directly over Kivalina
which you can see on this peninsula
right here landed in Kotzebue and met
with the leaders there and said this is
something we have to address if a
foreign power came and took one of our
towns
we would be up in arms about it we would
take up arms and we would defend our
towns and here we have a foreign power
the climate of the earth taking one of
our towns this is something we have to
address we have to be proactive about
and it's one of the reasons that
President Obama has put together the
clean power plan and the plan for how to
address this kind of climate disruption
we're on the ground in Kivalina were
funded and are winterizing the biochar
reactor for operations in Kivalina and
i'm happy to say that we have community
tribal corporate and mine support and
state-level support for building
sustainable sanitation and transportable
sanitation in the city of Kivalina that
quite frankly we'll have to relocate if
you put a traditional sewer system in
here and then had to relocate the town
you lose the entire capital with this
transportable sewage system in
sanitation system we'll be able to move
when the town needs to move and make a
more sustainable system that's really a
leapfrog technology another positive
outlier cellphones take over and we
never wired developing cities with
copper because we had wireless phones
why would we take a desert nation or a
desert country and put in a sewage
system that was designed for England in
the 1800s you know there's been very
little innovation in sanitation
our toilet training stops at the age of
two and her challenge and our
opportunity is to really identify better
practices I never thought it would
happen but in my studies in this I found
a toilet far better than Western toilets
and it's this understanding of improving
our sustainability to be able to go full
cycle cycle those nutrients get rid of
the pathogens and address these issues
sustainably that's our challenge in our
opportunity it's finding those positive
outliers so let's switch over to looking
at food security in the oceans a
daunting statistic ninety-four percent
of global warming today is in the
surface ocean in a in the form of a
thickening warm layer of water that
prevents the upwelling of nutrients
and the sustainability of phytoplankton
several papers by Baron Feld in 2006 in
Polo veena 2008-2009 have identified
over the last century the decrease in
plankton productivity over that time
scale they use secchi disk data which is
when you would take a disk of black and
white triangles lower it down from a
ship and see how far down you could
still see and that's a good proxy for
plankton they integrated the secchi disk
database with the satellite database
available in the last half of the 1900s
and they came up with some integrated
plots of primary productivity across the
entire world what they found was that
since 1950 the decrease in phytoplankton
and primary productivity in the seas may
exceed 40 percent so we we may have lost
40% of our primary productivity why is
that so important because a third of all
man's carbon that we've emitted over the
last 200 years into the atmosphere has
actually been absorbed by find a
plankton in the seas and is in the
oceans today so we've been getting a 33
percent discount now if this continues
business as usual pretty soon we're
going to get all the plankton we all the
carbon we paid for in the atmosphere
which is very daunting and it's another
example of a runaway feedback loop and
we have to be really aware of these
runaway feedback loops whether it's the
plankton here or the methane in the
Arctic Ocean because these are the
things that will trigger tipping points
and the tipping points may be points of
no return we call them event horizons
kind of like in them in the in the
science-fiction movies right if you get
too far into a black hole you cross an
event horizon there's no turning back
it's that kind of a tipping point we'd
like to avoid and stay away from the
event horizons that are going to make a
huge difference
plankton is one of those and the
question is what can we do to keep us
away from the event horizon of a runaway
feedback loop where we lost that
plankton productivity and so that's what
we look at in the oceans food security
in the oceans there have been a lot of
fish in the oceans traditionally we look
to some of the most positive outlier in
communities and ecosystems that we can
find and those I love this
community of kelp that we have just off
the coast of California why because this
macrocystis plant is one of the fastest
growing plants on earth it can grow over
two feet per day under optimal
conditions and it turns out it's not
cold water that they need it's high
level nutrients so it's the upwelling of
nutrients you may have heard that since
May 2014 the upwelling failed off the
coast of California
the net result we lost tens of thousands
of pinnipeds we lost millions of
shorebirds and we never got the
upwelling and the productivity it was
devastating and that's continued to this
day so we have a serious problem with
primary productivity right off the shore
of California so the question is how can
what can we do to actually keep that
system going at a time when it's so
critical so these kelp forests are some
of the richest ecosystems on earth they
live on a little ribbon of land on the
edge of on the eastern let's say the
western edge of the continents the
eastern shores of the oceans where we
get a lot of upwelling and it's those
ribbons that keep us alive but as we get
more and more global warming in the
ocean I mean how much of the climate
disruption that we saw off the coast of
California was caused by global warming
of the sea and that's those are the key
problems and challenges that we're
trying to address with marine
permaculture what is a permaculture a
permaculture is understanding a natural
ecosystem and adapting it as little as
necessary to ensure sustainable
productivity for humans as well as the
ecosystem living hand-in-hand with
nature and the opportunity to take a
sustainable marine ecosystem and develop
marine permaculture on a much larger
scale is enormous it's one that
potentially requires no land area no
freshwater no external input of
nutrients and yet sustainably day in and
day out can restore fish restore
fisheries produce kelp and balance
carbon so I like to think of these kelp
leaves
as the world's most sustainable solar
cell because they self-assembling they
fix carbon they store energy locally
they don't require any electricity and
they don't require any land area so that
that's a that's another positive outlier
that I love left to think about and the
reason it's so scalable between here and
China and here in Australia there's a
hundred million square kilometres of
untapped subtropical and tropical oceans
what can you do with the hundred million
square kilometres we've developed marine
permaculture that are resilient to
shipping container ships aircraft
carriers and resilient to hurricanes
they decouple from the water when the
waves get too steep and too big the net
result is it's sustainable it can keep
going there's a company just south of
here called liquid robotics they're in
Sunnyvale they have successfully
navigated a wave glider from here to
Hawaii to Australia and they did it
using wave power bi-directional
satellite communications it's a
beautiful automated robot we hope with
our marine permaculture to build the
world's largest robots that will
navigate the seven seas while sustaining
the oceans and building and scaling this
beautiful marine permaculture of a kelp
forest on kalam square kilometre scales
traversing the Seas and to be harvested
at regular intervals kelp is a
billion-dollar industry you can produce
alginate carrageenan not to mention
habitat for forage fish and forage fish
is some of the best protein that you can
possibly eat in terms of health
sustainability omega-3 fatty acids
incredible benefits so we're seeing this
as a very scalable approach and I love
this picture of the earth where we
realize we really are the water planet
this is our opportunity to start
utilizing some of those underutilized
resources there's this wonderful kelp
leaf solar cell vision and I think that
scaling this type of approach is really
a key opportunity as we go forward from
the video which you may have seen
there's we have this notion of an
oceanic fish springs the 99% of that
ocean surface is aquatic desert that
aquatic desert is a nutrient desert the
nutrients are a mere 500 meters
below the surface and those few hundred
meters that have to be traversed have an
energy barrier that energy barrier is
thermal the cold water is denser than
the warm water at the surface how do we
solve that problem well we can use wave
energy an average of 2 meters waves
across the Pacific Ocean and a flapper
valve and a long cable to up well
nutrients to the surface as we
demonstrated in the last decade off
Hawaii that system still has a challenge
that you have cold water near the
surface it'll sink back down and go away
so we we demonstrated that it could be
done we had a beautiful natural
validation of this work in 2008 in our
work with the University of Hawaii after
2 days of operation of the system we
came back two weeks later and this 17
foot long whale shark was still circling
the ocean pumps eating all the
phytoplankton that we'd produced so this
is beautiful natural validation I could
have couldn't have written a script like
this but it happened all by itself the
the the in this case nature was telling
us we're on the right track there were
in addition forage fish game fish in an
amazing concentrations around this
oceanic pump system and that was the
inspiration to extend the system since
then over the last three years the Woods
Hole Oceanographic Institution the
Marine Biological lab and NOAA in Woods
Hole at the climate foundation we've
been developing marine permit cultures
with this task force the notion is to
take the original system of a wave
driven pump a valve and a way to get
that water up to the surface we pass it
through a heat exchanger and that heat
exchanger warms up the water to within
two degrees of the surface we found
something very interesting about
subtropical waters and that is the
surface waters are actually saltier than
the deep water why is that because
there's a vapp eraser' ffice you have a
lot of sunlight
there's evaporation one part per
thousand saltier what does that mean it
means that we can actually solve the
problem how do we do that the fresher
colder water goes up to the heat
exchanger the heat exchanger with an
approach temperature of two degrees
Celsius
means that the thermal difference well
the salinity difference can overcome the
thermal difference and you know the
water is two degrees colder it still
floats the net result is that when we
use diffuser pipes and we release the
water to the kelp forest the high
nutrient water floats to the surface
when it floats to the surface it fully
irrigates the kelp and whatever is not
used by the kelp is used by the
phytoplankton and those cyanobacteria we
were talking about earlier today
actually can do their work and restore
productivity and actually provide food
for forage fish so now we have food for
forage fish we have habitat for forage
fish in the kelp forests themselves and
we can grow a square kilometer of kelp
forests personally I'm looking forward
to diving on these kelp forests because
it'll be warm to a hundred foot
visibility and tons of fish forage fish
game fish sharks and tuna fish you name
it it's gonna be a wonderful future and
so we see an opportunity to develop
ecotourism in this area and that is who
wouldn't want to go diving on a pristine
kelp forest that's a beautifully warm
and and good visibility this kelp forest
in plan view looks like the bottom array
these heat exchangers would be an array
of tubes that would actually disposed at
a depth of 25 meters which is below the
depth of all the shipping and the kelp
forests then would operate here we
envision drag plates or steering
mechanisms that enable left-right
operations in fact research has been
done in New York on the steering of
these mechanisms in mesoscale eddies it
turns out at any given time there's a
hundred mesoscale that he's traversing
the Pacific Ocean these mesoscale eddies
are like little storm systems their
highs and lows and if you put not one
but several of these systems in a circle
the Wagen so to speak they can actually
provide nutrients to each other and this
is a key opportunity as we go forward to
be able to create trains of these
systems that can actually sustainably
produce fish and be harvested at regular
intervals
sweet they will kind of soft fairly
close to the portal and last 50 minutes
a few yeah very good before that happens
I'd like to ask I'm sorry to interrupt
wait are there any questions people
didn't ask didn't get answered all the
ones that you asked by email got
answered in that way that I can move
around but are there any questions
anybody asked while we're while we're
here while your complaint reads could
see it on video any worry okay good
that's great
things you've got it - so we've
developed some mechanical engineering on
how to effectively convert wave energy
to the - to the actual system itself we
have some designs that include wave
action cables connected to the the
valves the valves can be double-acting
they can work on the way up and they can
work on the way down and the notion of
one-way flapper valves oops and see if
this is working this one-way flapper
valve on the upstroke the top valves are
opening and on the down stroke the lower
valves are operating and that result is
you get twice as much pumping so we
envisioned be able to pump hundreds of
thousands of cubic meters of water per
day and we ran the calculation and ends
up off to look at the figures again but
the calculation was on the order of 60
tons of biomass fixed per day or
produced per day on a system of this of
this size so of several hundred thousand
cubic meters of upwelling so it ends up
it looks very scalable the kelp as it
turns out doesn't require cold water it
requires high nutrients and it turns out
California kelp thrives in 20 to 25
degrees Celsius water and Baja kelp
optimally grows at 25 to 30 Celsius
which is wonderful that's exactly the
temperature of the tropical waters that
we're seeking to to go into so as long
as we can provide the nutrients we can
sustainably keep the system going in
addition there are two other sources of
energy one of them is are the currents
of the mesoscale eddies which can
approach 20 centimeters per second
differential between 25 meters and 5
meters depth and secondly the stomm will
sell salt fountain which in 1952 was
determined to be a way to actually
perpetually run a system in these areas
of the ocean where you have salinity
differences warm salty water can be
denser than cool freshwater with a net
result that there's intermingling of the
waters themselves these are the regions
of the world that are most amenable to
this type of salt inversion many major
parts of the ocean are amenable to that
and here's a illustration showing the
sinking salt fingers and the rising
fresh fingers that work on a very small
scale as well as larger scale so this is
the bit a vision of a salt fountain
affect the energies levels are smaller
but indulge rooms or other conditions
it's a third form of energy we can
harness to do the upwelling without
requiring external energy sources in
addition Phillie echo from Cooper Union
in New York has research conducted on
robotic geophysical fluid dynamics and
that is how do you get robots to net
sustainably navigate the seven seas in
mesoscale Eddie's and station keep
actually without any external use of
power just using the sub the currents
themselves be able to navigate into and
out of these mesoscale at ease and stay
where you want to in the ocean and
that's a key sustainability opportunity
as we see going forward some experiments
have validated the results with the
results indicating that it's quite
feasible and amenable and here's a
beautiful picture of the liquid robotics
wave glider crossing the Pacific Ocean
which we see as a vision for the future
we just need to scale this up by a
factor of a thousand that's something we
look forward to getting your help doing
please feel free to reach out and join
us in any of these efforts to try to
make a sustainable difference as we go
forward and truly try to make a
difference so I'd like to say live lean
and prosper and I think it's all about
living sustainably and thank you very
much for your attention
you